♪♪
-Please welcome Miley Cyrus
and Pete Davidson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Came out hot.
-What up?
-Wow. Good to see you.
Nice to see you.
That's -- Come on.
-How are you?
-Looking fantastic.
-We came in hot.
-You really came in hot.
Now, guys,
here's how this works.
In front of us each
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true. The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then they have to come to
a unanimous decision --
is it the truth or is it a lie?
Miley, you will go first.
Audience, which envelope
should she open?
1 or 2?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Always.
-Always 1?
-Number 1. Let's go.
-Let's start taking notes.
-Alright.
-[ Clears throat ]
"One time,
Flavor Flav introduced me
to a group of people
as Gwen Stefani."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-If this is a lie, I --
-I recently have met
Flavor Flav.
-Oh, yeah, okay.
-This is very believable.
-Okay.
This is very interesting, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I, too, have met Flavor Flav.
Where was it?
-Where was it?
It was at a radio-show event.
So in front of a lot of people.
-Introduced you onstage?
-And he was like "Gwen Stefani!"
-He went "Gwen..." for like --
it's still happening somewhere
in another universe.
It's still happening.
-I think that's true.
-And did you come out?
Did you say like,
"Hey, everybody,
I'm not Gwen Stefani"?
-Well, I was very excited to
debut what I thought was
a new and original look with my
red lipstick and blonde hair.
And it was kind of
disappointing,
'cause I love Flavor Flav.
-And you were also dating
Blake Shelton at the time.
-Yes.
-So that's very confusing.
-Yeah, it was very confusing.
-I think this is funny,
and I think it's a true story.
-I think it's super-true.
-I think it's true.
-When do I say?
-Yes, now.
-It's true.
-Yeah.
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, buddy.
-There we go.
-That's very true.
-Yeah.
-Are you kidding me?
-No.
-So, you're debuting a new look,
and you're like, "Here we come."
-But it was really good.
You know, I was with my dad,
and he said like,
"Who is Gwen Stefani?"
And that made me feel better.
-Okay, good, good. Yeah.
-But my dad
lives on another planet
and hasn't left the farm
since 1992, but...
-That's not bad. I love that.
Okay, here we go.
It's my turn.
Which envelope
should I open, guys?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Why is it 2 for me
and 1 for you?
-I like it.
-2, okay. 2.
"The last time I had
a Big Mac was in 2006
with Tobey Maguire after
an Arctic Monkeys concert."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-I feel you.
-There's no way you're not
having Big Macs, dude.
You're too --
-Do I look like --
-You're Cool Boy Fallon, man.
There's no way you're not out
at 2:00 in the morning
getting a nice Big Mac.
-What's your favorite
Arctic Monkeys song?
-To be honest,
I can't remember one song.
-See? It's a lie.
-It's not true.
-It's not true. Yeah.
-No, I saw the whole concert.
I just don't remember
any song from --
-No way.
-Nope.
No.
-No way, dude.
No way.
-That's not true.
You are so bad at this.
-You name me --
-You are so --
-You name me an
Arctic Monkeys song.
-I don't even know
what the [bleep] they are.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what I'm saying.
But I went. I did.
I went to a concert with
Tobey Maguire
after our late-night show.
-Tobey Maguire in 2006 --
very believable.
-He kept saying,
"It's my cheat night."
-Yeah?
-I still --
-No way. No way, dude.
We're having Big Macs
right after this.
-Uh-huh.
You smell like
Big Macs right now.
-Yeah.
It's the Irish.
-That is a lie, yeah.
You guys got me.
That is a total lie.
[ Buzzer ]
I do...
I've never seen them
in concert, also,
but I don't like Big Macs,
by the way.
I'm more of a
Quarter Pounder type of dude.
-Are they like a Blue Man Group?
-No. They're a famous band.
-Oh.
-But I had a whole fake lie --
Whatever. You guys got me.
Alright, here we go.
Pete, it's your turn.
-Alright, guys.
-What do you think?
2 or number 1?
-1?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-You guys got 1. I got 2.
-This is very specific.
-"There's no way
you're not throwing
Big Macs down at 2:00 a.m."?
-Come on, Jimmy and the boys?
Jimmy gets down with the boys.
-I got to go have a Big Mac.
-A lot of you guys
don't know about Jimmy.
Jimmy's a little boy.
-Hey.
-Okay.
-Mm-hmm.
-I don't even know if --
Alright.
I should read the e-mails
that they send out...
-Yeah, sorry.
Yeah, before the show?
-...before you come to the show.
-Yeah, sorry about that. Yeah.
-Okay. "I got caught by the cops
while smoking my first joint."
♪♪
-It almost seems too obvious.
-It seems really obvious.
-Yeah.
But you got caught by the cops
the first time
you ever smoked a joint?
-Yeah, the first time I
ever smoked a joint, it was --
We skipped school.
We went to the train station,
and, for some reason,
we thought smoking in a
train station was very discreet.
-This already sounds like
a stereotyp--
This is, like --
-Yeah, it sounds like
a scene from
"The Outsiders" or something.
-I think he just --
-Yeah.
-So, this is in Staten Island?
-This is in Staten Island.
Staten Island.
Staten Isle. Whoa.
-Oh.
-And, so you --
-The cop was like,
"Oh, is that a joint?"
-"You got to
smoke it like that."
-Oh.
-Alright, so, did you know
you were going to smoke pot?
-We made a plan.
I skipped math class,
because, you know, I was like,
"I'm never going
to figure it out, ever.
Why...
You know, might as well get into
this thing for the next --
I guess rest of my life."
And I went with
this guy I met, Mike.
And we went out to
the train station.
We rolled up a blunt at
the train station
and smoked it there.
-Don't they always say
that, like,
a lie just has
way too many details?
Like, this seems too detailed.
There's no way you remember --
You smoke a lot of weed.
You don't remember this story
in this much detail
if it really happened.
-Yeah, right? Mike.
His name was --
This guy named Mike.
-Yeah, Mike.
I would say his last name,
but I don't know what
he's doing right now.
-Do you even remember
the flight here yesterday?
-Yeah, exactly.
-Unh-unh.
-Wait. I don't know.
Did you eat a Big Mac after?
-[ Laughs ] With the boys.
Of course. Yeah, of course.
Always with the boys.
-I vote lie.
-I go with Miley's gut.
I'm going to say --
But, also -- Wait.
Pete's luck.
Pete Davidson's luck.
-Pete don't miss.
-That we know.
-The reason that
he's a comedian is 'cause
things like this happen
to him in real life.
-Just the details seemed like
you were trying to oversell it.
-Okay. I agree.
I'm with Miley.
It didn't happen.
[ Drum roll ]
-It is true.
-What?
[ Buzzer ]
-Yeah. And...
So, this is what --
This is -- By the way,
kids at home,
this is how you get out of
when you busted with drugs.
This is how you get out of it.
So...
[ Laughter ]
No, it's important. Yeah.
For your kids, as well. So...
"When Uncle Pete
comes to party."
-"Uncle Pete."
-"Hey! Oh!"
So, we went to
the train station.
We walked back up.
And these
two cops follow us, right?
So, I obviously know
they're cops,
because I grew up in, like,
a, you know, blue-collar
fireman/cop --
Everybody -- you know what
they look like.
-Yeah.
-So, my boy goes, "Oh, no."
And he just starts
running, right?
So they go, obviously, and
tackle him and put him in cuffs,
and I just stand there.
And they're like,
"Go against the car."
And I'm like,
"You know what, guys?
You know, you did your job.
I got --"
-How old are you?
-I'm like 16.
I was like, "You know,
I got busted with weed."
You know, I'm not going to try
and run from this, you know?
This is -- I skipped school.
I was a bad boy today."
And they wrote down
all my information.
They wrote down
my buddy's information.
And they were like, "Alright.
You can go back to class
because you're a stand-up guy.
As for your friend?
Right to the slammer."
-Wow. That is a lesson to be
learned right there.
A lesson to be
learned out there.
-Always succumb.
-My thanks to Miley Cyrus,
Pete Davidson.
Please welcome
Millie Bobby Brown.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi. Perfect.
That's Millie Bobby Brown.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Millie, nice.
You came right in there.
Millie and I will be
facing off against
one of her co-stars on
"Stranger Things."
Please welcome the one-and-only
Noah Schnapp.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
Okay.
-Don't get scalded
by the coffee.
You okay, buddy?
You came in hot, buddy. Wow.
-I did not expect that.
-Yeah, came in hot there.
Alright, perfect.
Alright, here's how this works.
-I'm so sorry.
-No, it's too late now.
-Only Noah.
-Alright.
In front of each of us...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
In front of each of us
are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true.
The other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then you have to come
to a unanimous decision --
is it a truth or a lie?
Millie,
you're going to go first.
Which envelope should she open?
What do you think?
1 or 2?
-Oh, we pick?
-Yeah, or the audience
could pick.
What do you think?
-2.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
2.
-Everyone said 2.
I don't know why.
-"I sneak my pet bunny
into hotels."
♪♪
-That's...
-You know Millie very well.
-I think that sounds
like it could be real.
-Why would you sneak your bunny?
Why can't you just check it in?
-Millie's, like,
obsessed with animals.
-Alright. But why do you
have to sneak it in?
-Because, usually,
they let in dogs and cats,
but probably not a rabbit.
You know?
It might become an issue.
-What do you mean, might?
Because that feels like --
Well, you would know
it's an issue, right, if you
already -- If you tried --
-I feel like Millie, though,
wouldn't be sneaky about it.
She would just walk in.
-Yeah, because
she loves animals.
Yeah, she would just
walk in and say,
"Hey, I have my bunny with me."
-Yeah, she wouldn't care.
-Everyone loves you.
Everyone would let you in
with anything.
You can go in with a chainsaw
and like,
"Yeah, I'm going to go to
my room with a chainsaw."
They'd go, "Millie, come on in.
We love you."
-Maybe.
-I don't think --
-I'm saying lie.
-Oh, wait. Whoa, whoa. Wait.
-But then I've got to
pay a deposit
if he does something, right?
It's like, ugh,
do I really want to do that?
No.
-She's so lying.
Are you kidding me?
She's such a liar.
-Why would you stay in a hotel?
Don't you live in England?
-I do, but I was
filming in the city.
-No, this is --
-You couldn't commute?
-I know when she's acting.
-I couldn't.
-This is a lie.
-This is a total,
complete, absolute lie.
-Like, you can't even try.
-You can't even describe this.
This is such a lie.
Tell us right now --
truth or lie?
[ Drum roll ]
-It's the truth.
-No.
-Oh, come on.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Guys.
-You played us.
-Why did I come here?
-Dude.
-You played us like
a deck of cards.
-Wait.
I said truth in the beginning.
-Yeah, you did say -- Yeah.
-I knew it.
My instincts said true.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, no. It's a true story.
And it did become an issue.
Like, the guy --
-Did they find it?
-They did.
I went into the elevator,
and I would put him
under my sweater.
And if they asked,
"I'm breast-feeding my child.
Why would you ever ask me?"
-That's not what you say.
No, you go,
"Hey, this is cashmere."
-"That's so inappropriate.
Where's your H.R. lady?"
Anyways...
And then, he buzzes
when he gets really happy,
and he was buzzing
under my shirt.
And his ear came out
of my shirt,
and the guy looks.
And I went, "Look away."
And I got off.
And then I put on my
"do not disturb" sign
on my door for like five days.
-So you did get away with it.
-I did, I did, yeah.
-Oh, my. Alright. Good job.
Congrats. Good on you.
-Oh, I knew.
-You got points for that one.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. It's my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
-Oh, my God.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Dude.
-1.
-We'll go with 1.
-Okay, be careful, 'cause I
don't want to be able
to see through -- Okay.
Oh, yeah, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
-I'm reading it to you, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah. I got worried.
-"LeBron James called me
from the court during a game."
-That's so cool.
-That's really cool.
I think it's almost
too cool...for you.
-For me?
[ Laughter ]
That's so funny.
"I think it's almost
too cool...for you."
Yeah.
-Okay. When?
-This was probably about
four years ago.
-Who were they playing?
-Oh, four years ago?
-They were playing the Nuggets.
Or, no, the Warriors.
The Warriors.
Golden State Warriors.
-What'd you talk about?
-What do you mean?
They didn't have a chat.
He was just --
-He called you.
Well, he called you.
Did you answer?
-Yes, I did.
-And what'd you say?
-So, what happened was,
I went --
-You're lying.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he's lying.
-I feel like I almost --
-I'm going to take this.
I'm gonna dip this in
a little bit more coffee
and let you think.
Think it over.
-Okay, what do we say?
-Ew.
-What are we saying?
What are we saying?
-What is that?
-Alright, together.
-It's a lie.
[ Drum roll ]
-It is a lie, yeah.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-He would never do that.
He would never do that.
-Never do that.
-He would never do that
during a game.
You knew it.
Noah, it is your turn.
Noah, which one?
-1.
-Okay, 1.
-Come on, bud. We got this.
Enola, let's put our
detective skills to the test.
-"I guilt-tripped Shawn Mendes
into following me back
on Instagram."
-This is something he would do.
-It sounds like something --
Yeah, it sounds like --
When is this?
-A year or two ago.
-Okay, why did you
guilt-trip him?
He didn't want to follow you?
-Well, he followed everyone else
in the cast except me.
-Shawn Mendes?
-Yeah. He followed you, Sadie,
Gaten, Caleb -- everybody.
-Oh, he's bitter.
-What's his problem?
-Yeah, he's mad.
-This is real.
-And I was like, "What the heck?
Why does he
follow everyone but me?"
-Yeah, what's
Shawn Mendes' problem?
-You're lying.
-He has beef with me.
-So, then how did you
get ahold of Shawn Mendes?
-I DM'd him and I was like,
"I'm low-key offended.
Why do you follow everyone --"
-Did you say,
"I'm low-key offended"?
You said that to him?
-You can't DM someone
if they're not following you.
He's lying.
-No, no, no, no.
Jimmy, that's not -- Jimmy...
-What, Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, am I -- Did I just
show how old I am?
-He showed his age there.
-Shh.
-Okay. I thought you had to
follow each other to DM.
-No!
-No, you can DM anybody.
-You can DM anybody?
-Jimmy, Jimmy, stop.
You need to stop.
-I'm not even on --
I'm on BeReal now.
-Oh, he's so hip.
-I don't even care.
-What did he say?
-Yeah, what did "Men-Men" say?
-He said, "Oh, what's up, man.
Like, I love you so much."
-He does say, "What's up, man?"
He does use the word "man."
He's like, "Hey, man."
He's Canadian.
-He's a fellow Canadian.
And he was like --
-Shawn -- Well,
he's a very nice guy, Shawn.
-Oh, I'm sweating.
-When is the last time you
talked to Shawn on Instagram?
-I called him the other day.
-Oh.
-That is absolutely --
This is such a lie.
-Yeah.
-That was what -- That's it.
It's over. It's over.
-It's a lie.
-You called him the other day?
Why would you call him if you
have him on -- If you're DMing?
I'm going to say it's a lie.
-It's a lie.
-It's...the truth.
-What?
[ Buzzer ]
Wow.
Wow. Acting. Acting.
Mastermind. Noah Schnapp.
-Oh, my God!
-He did it again.
-My thanks to
Millie Bobby Brown,
Noah Schnapp.
"Bron-Bron," give me a call.